if you look at a number line here and we
have this solution set graphed on the
number line okay from negative 3 to 7
what you would normally do is you'd say
like this X is greater than negative 3
but not equal to and X is less than or
equal to 7 so that closed circle means
equal to the open means not equal to and
you can see X is sandwiched in between
the two values now when you switch to
the interval notation you still think
about the number line in and working
from left to right or from low to high
and so you can say okay here's negative
3 and here's 7 right but negative 3 I'm
going to use a parenthesis or a curved
bracket indicating that it's not
including negative 3 or it's open all
the values up to 7 and including 7 we
use the square bracket so that tells us
this is like a closed circle okay so if
you can think about it on the number
line it'll be easy to think of low to
high or left-to-right and you just have
to think about whether it's a open which
is a parenthesis
not including that point or a square
bracket closed it does include that
point let's look at another example this
one here before we would have said X is
less than or equal to 5 equal to because
it includes that point the last thing
because you're shading to the left but
when you're working with the interval
notation you think about going from left
to right or low to high and you can see
this goes all the way to negative
infinity right so negative infinity all
the way up to 5 including 5 so we'll use
a square bracket now